This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Here at 99PI, we're in the business of making dreams come true. And boy, did we ever deliver this week. Sorry, I'm in awe. We are in a back room, and I'm like, what am I looking at? It's a hollowed ground. Yes.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在99PI，我们的业务就是让梦想成真。天哪，我们这周真的做到了。抱歉，我太震撼了。我们在一个里屋里，我心想，我看到的是什么？这是一片神圣的土地。没错。
You guys. It's a cast of a T-Rex. It's a T-Rex. That's actor, reporter, and our good buddy, Galeon Jacobs. As you could tell, I was crawling out of my skin with excitement. I recently got sent down into the deepest depths of the American Museum of Natural History in New York City. Dr. Michael Novichek, curator of paleontology, was showing me a fossil vault aptly named the Big Bone Room. Oh my gosh.
天哪。这是一个霸王龙的铸模。这是一只霸王龙。那是演员、记者兼我们的好朋友加利昂·雅各布斯。正如你所看到的，我兴奋得快要起鸡皮疙瘩了。我最近被带到了位于纽约市的美国自然历史博物馆的最深处。古生物学馆长迈克尔·诺维切克博士正带我参观一个被恰如其分地命名为“大骨头室”的化石库房。哦，天哪。
So can you describe this room that we're in? This is a room full of Big Bones. Oh, my God. This is not open to the public. Dinosauru. Dinosaur Corm. And you can see some of these. bones are massive. Dinosaurs and I go way back. My mother worked at the Carnegie Museum of Natural
那你能不能描述一下我们现在所在的这个房间？这是一个摆满了大骨头的房间。哦，天哪。这里不对公众开放。恐龙。恐龙角。你可以看到其中一些骨头非常巨大。我和恐龙有着很深的渊源。自我很小的时候起，我母亲就在卡耐基自然
History when I was really little. My grandmother made me a T-Rex costume for Halloween. And when I got a little older, I was even a teen docent. But as much as Gillian wanted to learn about all the dinosaurs themselves, we sent her to the American Museum of Natural History for a much different reason. Some good old-fashioned gossip. How resonant is that story with paleontalism? today. Is it one that's still known, or is it kind of receding into the annals of history? Oh, every paleontologist knows this story, you know, just about, I would think. And it's, it's well known, it's famous, it's part of the lore, it's part of the history. It's not a very noble history. They weren't very noble people. It's a scientific lore so unhinged that it has its
历史博物馆工作。我奶奶为我万圣节做了一套霸王龙服装。当我再大一点的时候，我甚至还当过青少年讲解员。但尽管吉莉安很想了解恐龙本身，我们送她去美国自然历史博物馆的原因却大不相同。一些精彩的老式八卦。这个故事与当今的古生物学有多大的共鸣？这是一个至今为人所知的故事，还是说它正在淡出历史的长河？哦，每个古生物学家都知道这个故事，我想，几乎所有人都知道。它非常知名，它是传奇的一部分，是历史的一部分。这不是一段多么高尚的历史。他们也不是什么高尚的人。这是一段极其离谱的科学传奇，以至于它拥有
own name, The Bone Wars. This story has everything. Backstabbing, sabotage, congressional hearings, bankruptcy, and lots and lots of dinosaur bones. It was a feud that shook paleontology to its very core and took science out of the museums and lecture halls and onto the pages of tawdry newspapers. Out of this nasty battle, paleontology came to capture the public's imagination and would become foundational to natural history museums across the country.
自己的名字——骨头大战。这个故事应有尽有。背叛、破坏、国会听证会、破产，以及数不清的恐龙化石。这是一场震撼了古生物学根基的恩怨，它将科学从博物馆和演讲厅带到了低俗报纸的版面上。正是通过这场丑陋的争端，古生物学最终俘获了公众的想象力，并成为全美自然历史博物馆的基石。
And without it, elementary school field trips today would look very different. Although fossils are famously very, very old, paleontology as a formal science is actually pretty new. It's only around, I would say, in the 18th century, that European scientists began to systematically study fossils and began using fossils as evidence for trying to understand the history of life on Earth and eventually the evolution of life on Earth. That's Lucas Rappell,
如果没有它，如今的小学生实地考察旅行将会大不相同。尽管化石以极其古老而闻名，但作为一门正式科学的古生物学其实相当年轻。直到18世纪左右，欧洲科学家才开始系统地研究化石，并开始将化石作为证据，试图了解地球上生命的历程，并最终了解地球上生命的进化。说话的是卢卡斯·拉佩尔，
associate professor of history at Brown and author of Assembling the Dinosaur. He says that Europeans dominated the field during paleontology's nascent years, and one of the most consequential and most overlooked was a British woman named Mary Anning. In 1812, at the age of 12, she discovered an ichthyosaurus skeleton along England's Jurassic coast. Natural history was considered a respectable, pious leisure pursuit, which is to say that regular people, including working class people, were encouraged in Victorian. in England to study natural history. It would take a few more decades for paleontality to take off in the United States,
布朗大学历史系副教授，《组装恐龙》一书的作者。他说，在古生物学的萌芽期，欧洲人主导了这一领域，其中最重要却又最被忽视的人物之一是一位名叫玛丽·安宁的英国女性。1812年，年仅12岁的她在英国侏罗纪海岸发现了一个鱼龙骨架。自然历史曾被认为是一种体面的、虔诚的休闲追求，也就是说，在维多利亚时代的英国，普通人，包括工人阶级，被鼓励去研究自然历史。又过了几十年，古生物学才在美国兴起，
despite North America being home to some of the most impressive prehistoric specimens in the world. And that's mostly because American scientists were seen as upstarts. So they were not taken very seriously by Europeans. And that was generally true, not just for science. So the United States had kind of, I would say, a cultural inferiority complex for much of the 19th century, a lot of Americans saw themselves as being less erudite, less learned, right? Kind of a younger culture, a less sophisticated culture, and science was no exception.
尽管北美拥有世界上一些最令人印象深刻的史前标本。这主要是因为美国科学家被视为暴发户。因此，他们并没有被欧洲人太当回事。这种情况不仅普遍存在于科学界。因此，在19世纪的大部分时间里，美国人有一种文化自卑情结，许多美国人认为自己不那么博学，没那么有学问，对吧？这是一个比较年轻的文化，一个不太成熟的文化，科学也不例外。
And in the middle of the 19th century, two men hoped to distinguish not just American paleontology, but themselves, as scientifically worthy. Edward Drinker Cope was born in 1840, two years before the word dinosaur was even coined, He came from a wealthy Quaker family in Pennsylvania and took an immediate liking to natural history as a child. He even published his first scholarly article at age 19. And he just started, you know, a force of personality to wage a career in science, much to his father's dismay. This is Mark Jaffe, author of The Gilded Dinosaur. He says that Cope was a bit of a von der Kendt.
在19世纪中叶，有两个人希望不仅让美国古生物学，也让其自身在科学上获得认可。爱德华·德林克·科普出生于1840年，甚至在“恐龙”这个词被创造出来两年前。他出生于宾夕法尼亚州一个富裕的贵格会家庭，从小就对自然历史产生了浓厚的兴趣。他在19岁时甚至发表了他的第一篇学术文章。正如你所知，他凭借强大的个人魅力开始在科学界闯荡，这让他的父亲大为惊慌。说话的是《镀金恐龙》一书的作者马克·杰夫。他说科普有点像个狂热分子。
Despite attending some university courses, because Cope had very little formal training and was mainly self-taught. Well, I think it always made himself conscious. And you felt, you know, he had to prove himself more. Cope was what you would call a gentleman scientist. He funded his work independently and was driven by his own personal curiosity. He was an exuberant theorist, is how I would put it. So he was someone who, he was kind of a dreamer in some ways.
尽管上过一些大学课程，但由于科普几乎没有受过正规训练，主要靠自学。嗯，我想这总是让他感到自我意识过剩。你觉得，你知道，他必须更多地证明自己。科普就是你所说的那种绅士科学家。他独立资助自己的工作，并由个人的好奇心驱动。我是这样评价他的：他是一个热情洋溢的理论家。所以他某种程度上是个梦想家。
So he really enjoyed coming up with fantastic, often quite baroque theories of evolution. He was a great opponent of Charles Darwin's theory of evolution. So he'd all these, like, very elaborate, somewhat crazy ideas about how living beings evolve. But as creative as he was, he had one fatal flaw. Yeah, he was temperamental and sort of volatile. You know, he had a really stormy personality.
所以他真的很喜欢提出那些离奇的、通常相当巴洛克式的进化理论。他是查尔斯·达尔文进化论的强烈反对者。因此，他提出了所有这些非常精心制作的、甚至有点疯狂的想法，关于生物是如何进化的。但尽管他极具创造力，他却有一个致命的缺点。是的，他性格暴躁、有些反复无常。你知道，他有着非常暴烈的人格。
The personality characteristics, I think, that sort of set the table on the Cope side, of the battle. On the other side of that battle was an American paleontologist named Otneill Charles Marsh. He was also a man of three names, but differed from the young ingenue cope in many ways.
我认为，这些性格特征为科普在这场战斗中的阵营奠定了基调。这场战斗的另一方是一位名叫奥特尼尔·查尔斯·马什的美国古生物学家。他也是一个拥有三个名字的人，但在很多方面与年轻的天才科普截然不同。
For one, he had a much slower, much steadier approach to the scientific process. Whereas cope was given to bold theorizing, Marsh was a dogged empiricist, by which I mean that his obsession was really collecting more fossils,
首先，他对科学进程采取了更慢、更稳的方法。如果说科普喜欢大胆的理论化，那么马什则是一个顽固的经验主义者，我的意思是，他的痴迷真正体现在收集更多化石上，
describing those fossils, really doing the kind of painstaking work of describing the anatomy of each individual fossil in a great detail, and not speculating too much about the relationship between those fossils and even less so about the kind of evolutionary history of those fossils. So he was much more, in some ways, more careful, more empirical in his approach. Also, according to written and photographic documentation, he both looked and acted like a curmudgeonly cartoon walrus. Marsh was stalky, he was more of a loner, a confirmed bachelor, quote-unquote.
对这些化石进行描述，真正去做那些煞费苦心地详细描述每个独立化石解剖结构的工作，而不是对这些化石之间的关系进行过多猜测，对这些化石的进化史更是如此。所以在某种程度上，他的方法更加谨慎，更加经验主义。此外，根据文字和照片记录，他的长相和行为都像一只脾气暴躁的卡通海象。马什身材粗壮，更喜欢独处，是个“名副其实”的单身汉。
I never quite know exactly what to read into that. Also quite arrogant. He loved telling stories in which he was the hero of the story. Let's put it that way. Of the two, I've read a lot of their letters and publications, and Marsh just must have been a terrible person. He just seems like just someone that you would not want to spend a lot of time around. Marsh's father struggled financially, and his family grew up poor.
我从来不太确定该如何理解这一点。而且相当傲慢。他喜欢讲那些他是英雄的故事。这么说吧。在这两人中，我读过很多他们的信件和出版物，而马什一定是个很糟糕的人。他看起来就是那种你不想花太多时间和他在一起的人。马什的父亲经济拮据，他的家人是在贫困中长大的。
He may have had to abandon science altogether had it not been for one stroke of good fortune. He was the nephew of one of the earliest and most important financial capitalists in the history of American capitalism, George Peabody. Peabody bankrolled a Yale education for his nephew, but that wasn't all. At this time, there were very few opportunities to pursue paleontology. So Marsh got Unkey George to create one for him. George Peabody ended up endowing a museum at Yale University, named after him, the Peabody Museum of Natural History. But there were strings attached. So he endowed that museum on the condition that Yale University hire his nephew, give him a job as curator.
要不是有一件幸运的事，他可能已经彻底放弃科学了。他是美国资本主义历史上最早、最重要的金融资本家之一乔治·皮博迪的侄子。皮博迪资助了侄子在耶鲁大学的教育，但还不止于此。当时，从事古生物学的机会非常少。于是马什让乔治叔叔为他创造了一个。乔治·皮博迪最终在耶鲁大学捐赠了一座以他名字命名的博物馆——皮博迪自然历史博物馆。但这是有附加条件的。因此，他捐赠这座博物馆的条件是耶鲁大学必须雇用他的侄子，给他一份馆长的工作。
So it was like, Marsh was kind of the original Nepo baby, you could say. This dependence on wealthy benefactors would be a running theme through paleontology's fledgling years. In fact, paleontology, as we know it today, owes its existence to robber-barren capitalism. In the second half of the 19th century, wealthy guys like John D. Rockefeller, Andrew Carnegie, and J.P. Morgan were sitting on an obscene share of America's wealth and power. This did not sit well with the rest of the population. But it's not like they were willing to pay people fairly or improve labor practices to correct that. These wealthy elites wanted to paint over the concerns about this obvious wealth gap by providing the public with the types of grand institutions one may find in Europe, things like libraries, symphony halls,
所以就像，马什可以说是最初的“关系户”。这种对富有赞助商的依赖将贯穿古生物学初期的整个过程。事实上，正如我们今天所知，古生物学要归功于强盗男爵式的资本主义。在19世纪下半叶，像约翰·D·洛克菲勒、安德鲁·卡内基和J·P·摩根这样富有的人掌握了美国大部分的财富和权力。这让其余的人口感到不满。但这并不是说他们愿意公平地付钱给工人或改善劳工做法来纠正这一点。这些富有的精英们希望通过向公众提供欧洲那种宏伟的机构，比如图书馆、交响乐厅，
and most importantly to the field of paleontology, natural history museums. These museums had multiple functions, but among other things, they were part of a PR campaign. The other function of these museums was to legitimize and justify the, tremendous concentration of wealth that was a product of American style capitalism in the late 19th century. And so for the museum to succeed
以及对古生物学领域最重要的自然历史博物馆，来掩盖公众对这种明显财富差距的担忧。这些博物馆有多重功能，但除此之外，它们还是公关活动的一部分。这些博物馆的另一个功能是使19世纪末美式资本主义产生的巨额财富集中合法化并合理化。因此，为了让博物馆在
at that second function, at that kind of legitimizing function, the museums had to attract a popular audience, a working class audience. These new natural history museums would be open to the general public. And what the public wanted to see was the biggest, baddest, most
第二个功能即合法化功能上取得成功，博物馆必须吸引大众观众，吸引工人阶级观众。这些新的自然历史博物馆将向广大公众开放。而公众想看的是大自然所能提供的最大、最坏、最令人敬畏的物件。什么是最壮观的东西，能够吸引来自各行各业的各种人群来到自然历史博物馆？就是这些神奇的化石。随着自然历史博物馆的兴起，古生物学突然有了一个场地。那是富丽堂皇的大厅，等待着用骨头填满。科普和马什于1864年在柏林第一次见面。
awe-inspiring objects nature had to offer. What's the most spectacular thing that will draw all kinds of people from all walks of life into the natural history museum, it's these amazing fossils. With the rise of natural history museums, paleontology suddenly had a venue. They were grand palatial halls waiting to be filled with bones. Cope and Marsh met for the first time in Berlin in the year 1864. O.C. Walrus-faced Marsh was there studying at a German university.
长着海象脸的O.C.·马什当时正在德国的一所大学学习。而脾气暴躁的科普则在欧洲躲避内战征兵。马什和科普，他们一开始的关系，也许你可以说是相爱相杀，我也不太清楚。就像他们某种程度上，你知道，他们在相似的圈子里活动。他们都是对地质学、化石以及未来的发现感兴趣的自然主义者。他们实际上互相通信，甚至用对方的名字来命名化石。但这并没有持续多久。在见面短短几年内，两人就开始踩对方的脚了。真正的决裂始于薄板龙。再次有请马克·杰夫。
While the temperamental cope was in Europe dodging the civil war draft. Martian Cope, they started off as, maybe you could say like frenemies, I don't know exactly. Like they were sort of, you know, they ran in similar circles. They were both naturalists who were interested in geology, fossils, and the discoveries to come. They actually exchanged correspondence and even named fossils after one another. But that wouldn't last long at all. And within just a couple of years of meeting, the two began stepping on each other's toes. The real break comes with the Alasimosaurus. Mark Jaffe again.
1868年，科普是费城自然科学学院的馆长。当时，他仍然只有28岁。他的任务是修复一种名为薄板龙的史前海洋生物的化石。这是一种长长的、蛇状的水生动物。薄板龙的长度可达43英尺，科普煞费苦心地重建了这具骨架。科普在给自然科学学院的描述中写道：
In 1868, Cope was curator of the Academy of Natural Sciences in Philadelphia. At the time, he was still only 28 years old. He was tasked with the restoration of a fossil of a prehistoric sea creature called the Elasmosaurus. And this was a long, snaky, aquatic animal. The Elasmasaurus could grow to 43 feet in length, and Cope had painstakingly reconstructed the skeleton. In Cope's description to the Academy of Natural Sciences, he wrote,
引述，“它拥有一条很长的尾巴，尾巴高高隆起、被压缩，适合用来在水中划动笨重的身体。”在重建模型的同时，他还发表了一篇详尽的学术论文，并配有详细的插图。他为自己的工作感到相当自豪。
quote, It possesses a tale of great length, which was elevated, compressed, and adapted for sculling the ponderous body through the water. And alongside the reconstruction, he published an extensive academic paper, complete with detailed illustrations. He was quite proud of his work.
直到他把作品拿给O.C.·马什看。马什来访时，科普向他展示了薄板龙，这又回到了那种争强好胜的心态。马什看了一眼说：“你把头安错地方了。”薄板龙化石要么有着非常非常长的脖子，要么有着非常非常长的尾巴。科普猜它有一条长尾巴。而他猜错了。科普将信将疑地请教了美国古生物学之父约瑟夫·莱迪来征求第二意见。他看了一眼，然后把骷髅从这一端拿起来走过去，这是一个相当长、相当大的动物，
until he shared it with O.C. Marsh. When Marsh was visiting, Cope showed him the Elasimosaurus, and again, this goes back to the one-offsmanship. Marsh looked at it and said, you've got the head on the wrong end. The Elasmosaurus fossil either had a very, very long neck or a very, very long tail. Cope guessed it had a long tail. And he guessed, wrong. Cope deferred to Joseph Lydie, the father of American paleontology, for a second opinion. He looked at it and he took the skull from the one end and walked, this is quite a long, big animal,
然后走到另一端，把它正好装进那里的一个插槽里。好吧，科普当然感到十分尴尬。而马什当然对自己很满意。受辱的科普疯狂地试图找出那篇惹麻烦的论文的每一份副本，悄悄地将其从全国各地的图书馆中撤下。而马什则设法获得了几份副本，并将它们当作小奖杯保存起来。出于某种原因，科普和马什觉得，没有什么比把这些细节搞对更重要的了。作为科学家，他们真的非常非常看重自己的声誉。
and walked to the other and fit it right into a socket there. Well, of course, Cope was mortified. And of course, Marsh was quite happy with himself. Humiliated, Cope frantically attempted to track down every copy of the offending paper, quietly removing it from libraries across the country. Marsh, for his part, managed to acquire several copies, and he kept them as little trophies. For some reason, Cope and Marsh, for them, there was just like nothing more important than to get these details right. As scientists, they were just really, really invested in their own reputations.
马什甚至将这一刻反思为他们的决裂点，他写道，引述：“当我把这件事告诉科普教授时，他受伤的虚荣心受到了沉重的打击，从此再也没有恢复过来，他自此成了我死敌。”学术政治有个有趣的地方。人们常说学术政治格外恶劣，因为其利害关系实在太低了。薄板龙事件使他们成了敌人，但正是他们自己的野心，将这种紧张关系升级为了一场全面的战争。我认为科普和马什在狂热中只是想扩大各自在整个领域的势力范围。而讽刺的是，他们确实做到了。这是艾米莉·格拉斯利，PBS系列节目《史前公路之旅》的主持人和
Marsh even reflected on this moment as their breaking point, writing, quote, when I informed Professor Copevitt, his wounded vanity received a shock from which it has never recovered, and he has since been my bitter enemy. There's a funny thing about academic politics. People often say that academic politics are especially vicious because the stakes are so low. The Elasmasaurus incident turned them into enemies, but it would be their own ambitions that would escalate their tension into an all-out war. I think Hope and Marsh in their frenzy wanted to just expand their own influence across the field. And the irony is that they did. This is Emily Grassley, host and Ron.
编剧。她说，在古生物学界，命名标本的权利就是一切。第一人，第一份描述，胜过后来的一切。因此，分类学家，也就是那些描述并发表新物种的人，他们处于独特的位置，因为他们得以让自己永垂不朽。马什和科普都想成为第一，第一个发现，第一个命名，第一个获得荣誉。但为了做到这一点，他们都必须将目光投向西方。到目前为止，我们的故事主要发生在美国东海岸。
writer of the PBS series Prehistoric Road Trip. She says that in the world of paleontology, the right to name a specimen is everything. The first person, the first description, trumps anyone that comes afterwards. So taxonomists, the people being those who describe and publish new species, they are uniquely positioned in that they get to immortalize themselves. Marsh and Cope wanted to be the first, the first to find, the first to name, the first to get the credit. But in order to do that, they would both have to look west. So far, our story has mostly taken place on the east coast of the United States.
马什在康涅狄格州的耶鲁大学，科普在费城。虽然那里也发生过重要的化石发现（特别鸣谢新泽西州），但真正改变游戏规则并把美国带上古生物学版图的化石是在美国西部。美国西部曾是、现在依然是各种类型化石的宝库。在19世纪70年代，美国西部的化石发现绝对不是什么新鲜事。原住民实际上在几千年前就已经发现了恐龙骨骼并与之互动了。
Marsh is at Yale in Connecticut, Cope in Philadelphia. And while there were important fossil finds taking place around there, special shout out to New Jersey, the fossils that really changed the game and put the United States on the paleontological map were in the American West. The American West was home to so many and remains home to so many different kinds of fossils. In the 1870s, fossil discovery in the American West was not at all new. Indigenous populations had already been finding and interacting with dinosaur bones literally for thousands of years.
但大约在这个时候，横贯大陆的铁路、“淘金”采矿业和“昭昭天命”论将美国的掠夺精神带到了西部。与所有这些不断扩张的利益密切相关的古生物学，也顺便搭了个便车。所以无论是木材、建筑材料还是农田，你知道，这就好比政府准备从本土土地上掠夺大量这些资源。而其中一种资源就是化石。今天，我们对科学家有一个既定的印象：白大褂、同行评审、机构资历、一套流程。
But around this time, the Transcontinental Railroad, the mining industry, and Manifest Destiny brought the American spirit of extraction to the West. Fallientology, which had close ties to all of these expanding interests, kind of hitched a ride along the way. So whether it was timber or building supplies or farmland, you know, it was sort of like the government was poised to extract so many of these resources from native lands. And one of those resources were fossils. Today we have a picture in our heads of what a scientist is, lab coats, peer review, institutional credentials, a process.
但在当时，几乎没有任何这样的基础设施。这里本质上就是古生物学的蛮荒西部。大约在1870年，O.C.·马什从纽黑文出发，代表皮博迪博物馆领导了一系列前往美国西部的大学考察队。他们发现了早期马的物种、有齿鸟以及翼龙的遗骸。占有欲极强的马什本可以宣称对整个西部拥有所有权，但它太广袤了，不能只留给他一个人。科普没有像耶鲁皮博迪这样的大机构的资金支持，但他有家族资金。他能够私下资助他的探险，而且他选择的地点基本上和马什建立据点的地方一模一样，事情也就是从这里开始失控的。最典型的故事就是布里杰盆地。
But during this time, almost none of that infrastructure existed. It was essentially the wild west of paleontology. Around the year 1870, O.C. Marsh set off from New Haven to lead a series of college expeditions of the American West on behalf of the Peabody Museum. They discovered early species of horses, toothed birds, and the remains of a pterosaur. Possessive as he was, Marsh would have staked a claim for the entirety of the West, but it was too vast to keep for just himself. Koch didn't have the financial backing of a big institution like the Yale P-body, but he did have family money. He was able to fund his expedition privately, and he chose essentially the exact same spot where Marsh had set up shop, which is where things started to go off the rails. The quintessential story is the Bridger Basin.
布里杰盆地是怀俄明州西南部的一个地点，基本上是脊椎动物化石的宝库。马什在那儿，科普也在那儿。他们同时在盆地里工作。各自的团队都在竞相将整个始新世脊椎动物栖息地的古老物种进行分类。犀牛、鳄鱼、骆驼、大得像灰熊的巨型陆龟。当时没有什么适当的出版标准协议。为了抢夺第一，科普和马什最终都声称自己完成了一些相同的发现。他们找到了相同的动物，
Bridger Basin was a site in southwestern Wyoming that was essentially a treasure trove for vertebrate fossils. Marsh was there, Cope was there. They were all working in the basin at the same time. Separately, their crews were racing to classify an entire ancient habitat of Eocene vertebrate species. Rhinos, crocodiles, camels, massive land turtles as big as grizzly bears. There were no proper protocols for publication standards. And in their mad rush to be the first, Cope and Marsh ended up claiming credit for several of the same discoveries. They found the same animals.
并给它们起了不同的名字。因此，花了多年时间才理清头绪。在这期间，一个化石甚至被赋予了七个不同的名字。最重要的是，他们还诉诸一些卑劣的科学破坏行为，把记录弄得一团糟。马什的人所做的事情之一就是制造了一个假化石。他们把一堆来自不同事物的骨头拼凑在一起，
and gave them different names. And so it took years to unravel. One fossil was given seven different names during this time. And on top of that, they were also making a mess of the record by resorting to some petty scientific sabotage. One of the things that the marsh people did was they created a false fossil. They put a bunch of bones together that came from all different things,
留给科普去发现，而他确实找到了。科普可能比马什更年轻，背景也更薄弱，但在这场竞争中他确实有一个优势。他是一位极其高产的出版者，能够以极快的速度炮制学术论文。科普比马什到得晚，在这期间还生了重病，但依然设法仅仅为了一种动物就发表了16篇文章。但由于他的速度，他的作品中也出现了许多错误，马什对此
leaving it for Cope to find, which he did. Cope may have been younger and less connected than Marsh, but he did have one advantage in this whole rivalry. He was an extraordinarily quick publisher who could churn out academic papers at a breakneck speed. Cope arrived later than Marsh and became severely ill during this time and still managed to publish 16 articles on one animal alone. But because of his speed, he also made a lot of mistakes in his work, which Marsh would
幸灾乐祸地指了出来。马什毫不留情。他对科普的每一个发现都提出质疑。这让科普感到非常痛苦。约瑟夫·莱迪，科普的前导师、当时美国古生物学界最受尊敬的名字，那年夏天也一直在布里杰盆地工作。他最终对这两个科学家的行事方式感到如此震惊，以至于彻底离开了这个领域。
gleefully point out. Marsh was relentless. He challenged every cope finding. It was just really just grinding for cope. Joseph Lydie, Copes' former mentor, and at this point, the most respected name in American paleontology, had also been working out of Bridger Basin that summer. He ended up being so appalled by how these two men of science conducted themselves that he left the field altogether.
他直接放弃了古生物学，去研究蠕虫了。还没等他们在布里杰盆地造成的混乱平息下来，另一个古生物学战场又出现了。1877年的某一天，一位名叫阿瑟·莱克斯的地质学家兼教授在科罗拉多州莫里森徒步时，偶然发现了世界上见过的最丰富的巨型化石矿藏之一。这就是著名的莫里森组。莫里森组最酷的地方在于，它保存的不仅是一种生物，艾米莉·格拉斯利又说道。
He just gave up on paleontology and studied worms. Before the dust could even settle from all the havoc they caused in Bridger Basin, another paleontological battlefield emerged. One day in 1877, a geologist and professor named Arthur Lakes was hiking through Morrison, Colorado, when he stumbled upon one of the richest deposits of absolutely enormous fossils the world had ever seen. It was a site known as the Morrison Formation. The cool thing about the Morrison Formation is it doesn't just preserve one kind of organism, Emily Grassley again.
它保存了整个侏罗纪时期的环境。所以从植物到最小的生物，再到地球上漫步过的最大动物，莫里森组中应有尽有。莱克斯立即写信给马什，告诉他自己的发现。他还通知了科普，不久两人再次大打出手。双方都派遣团队前往大致相同的区域，
It preserves the entire environment of the Jurassic period. So everything from plants to the smallest of organisms to the largest animals that ever roamed the earth, they're all represented in the Morrison formation. Lakes wrote to Marsh immediately about what he found. He also alerted Cope, and soon the two began battling it out again. Both men dispatched teams to roughly the same area,
有时挖掘地点只相距几英里。我想讽刺的是，莫里森组的面积绝对是巨大的。所以你本以为他们至少能稍微分开一点。你知道，就像是，老兄，你本该转学去另一所学校的。去科罗拉多得了。多疑的马什用代号指代科普，并从科普的团队中买通并挖走了一些成员。作为报复，科普则雇佣了恐龙“偷盗者”来抢在马什团队的前面挖掘化石。
sometimes digging within miles of each other. I think the irony is that the Morrison formation is absolutely massive. So you would have thought that they would have been able to split up a little bit further. You know, sort of like, man, you should have just transferred to a different school. Just go to Colorado. Paranoid, Marsh should refer to Cope by codenames and bribe members of Cope's team away from him. In retaliation, Cope would employ dinosaur rustlers to excavate fossil. out from under Marsh's team.
甚至还有记载称，这两个交战的阵营互相投掷石头，还有一个耸人听闻的指控，称马什的一名收集者在拿走他想要的所有化石后，竟然毁了一个挖掘点。而这，当然就是摧毁标本，对吧？
There are even accounts of the two warring camps throwing rocks at one another, and one salacious allegation that one of Marsh's collectors destroyed a dig site after taking all the fossils he wanted from it. And that, of course, is destroying specimens, right?
这摧毁了产出更多知识的基础，基本上，我的意思是，这与科学界至少是表面上的理想背道而驰。因此，骨头大战有趣的地方在于，
That's destroying the foundation for the production of more knowledge, which is basically, I mean, that's anathema to at least the stated ideals of the scientific community. So part of what's interesting about the bone wars
它揭示了科学家们通常喜欢呈现的方式与现实之间存在的巨大鸿沟：现实往往是非常卑劣的，往往是极其自私的，科学家们对获得荣誉的兴趣远大于对真正发展新理论的兴趣，等等等等。当怀俄明州地下的化石采集者们在进行肉搏战时，科普和马什却在学术论文中制造了一场绝对的闹剧。他们互相指责对方伪造发现日期、抄袭、搞裙带关系、当间谍，他们基本上是在所有的科学同行面前通过印刷品大吵大闹。
is that it reveals the kind of chasm that separates the way scientists often like to present from the reality, which is that it's often very petty, it's often very self-serving, that scientists are more interested in credit than they are in actually developing new theories and so on and so forth. While it was their fossil collectors on the ground in Wyoming who were doing the physical fighting, Cope and Marsh were creating an absolute spectacle in academic papers. They accused each other of fabricating discovery dates, of plagiarism, of subjugerism, spying, they were essentially brawling in front of all of their scientific peers in print.
甚至有一家著名的科学出版物不得不禁止他们互相批评。但既是因为也是尽管有西部这种激烈的竞争，我们今天才拥有了有史以来最著名的一些恐龙。马什描述并命名了诸如剑龙、异特龙和迷惑龙等恐龙，当然，我们正站在巨大的长颈恐龙雷龙——轰鸣的蜥蜴的独立骨架化石前。这是一种由马什命名的动物，也是有史以来发现的最早的恐龙化石之一，它展示了这些动物能变得多么庞大。这是耶鲁皮博迪博物馆脊椎动物古生物学和脊椎动物动物学副馆长巴特·安琼·比勒博士。这段历史可能低俗，
It was to the point that one prominent scientific publication actually had to ban them from criticizing each other. But both despite and because of this fierce competition in the West, today we have some of the most famous dinosaurs on record. Marsh described and named dinosaurs such as Stegosaurus, allosaurus, and apatosaurus, and of course, We're standing in front of an enormous freestanding fossil of the great long-neck dinosaur Brontosaurus, the thunder lizard. This was an animal named by Marsh, and it was one of the first dinosaur fossils ever discovered that showed just how Titanic these animals could become. This is Dr. Bart Unjun Bueller, Associate Curator of Vertebrate Paleontalian Tiber. and vertebrate zoology at the Yale Peabody Museum. This history may be tawdry,
但耶鲁皮博迪博物馆之所以能拥有如此多的化石收藏，都要归功于这场历史恩怨。我的意思是，只要有人类的地方，只要有野心勃勃的人的地方，就会有竞争。而在科普和马什的情况下，一笔突如其来的横财、一个非凡的宝藏第一次敞开大门，唾手可得，又有两个聪明、有野心且具备能力的人，这种情况就一定会发生。在这场战争中，马什占了上风。他拥有皮博迪博物馆。他拥有政治人脉。而且他能记仇记到骨子里。
but the Yale Peabody Museum has a lot of its fossil collection thanks to this historic beef. I mean, wherever there are people, wherever there are ambitious people, there is competition. And in the case of Copenhagen Marsh, a sudden windfall, an extraordinary treasure trove
但脾气暴躁的科普设法找到了绕过这一难关的方法，因为谁先发表谁就能获得荣誉。于是科普最终用自己的私房钱买下了一家名为《美国博物学家》的著名科学期刊，以加快他的出版速度。仅在1879年至1880年间，他就发表了76篇论文，试图用绝对的数量来压倒马什。1882年，马什进行了强有力的反击。他利用自己的政治人脉，为自己争取到了美国地质调查局首席古生物学家的职位，并利用这一权力切断了科普获得任何
opened for the first time, there for the taking, two men, intelligent, ambitious, and equipped to do it, you're going to have this happen. Throughout this war, Marsh had the upper hand. He had the Peabody Museum. He had political connections. And he could hold a wicked grudge.
政府资助的途径。科普在调查局的项目上失利了。而调查局给马什带来的是探索经费和出版经费。这再次证明，可怜的科普出局了。科普不幸地将大部分资金都用来购买《美国博物学家》，由于马什在高等教育界的盟友以及他自己糟糕的性格，他很难找到工作。
But temperamental cope managed to find a way around that because the first to publish was the first to get credit. So Cope ended up using his personal money to purchase a prominent scientific journal called the American Naturalist to fast-track his public. Between 1879 and 1880 alone, he published 76 papers attempting to overwhelm Marsh with the sheer volume. In 1882, Marsh struck back hard. He used his political connections to position himself to be named chief paleontologist at the U.S. Geological Survey, and he used that power to cut Cope off from any
科普将他剩下的遗产投资于西部的白银勘探，但这些投资失败了。他剩下的最大资产是他的个人化石收藏。破产且前途无望的科普退出了骨头大战。科普是个很有同情心的人。
government funding. Cope lost out on the surveys. And what the surveys gave Marsh was money for exploration, money for publication. And this was, again, poor Cope. He's out in the cold. Cope, unfortunately, had spent much of his money purchasing the American Naturalist and had a hard time finding employment thanks to Marsh's allies in higher education and also because of his terrible personality.
我的意思是，从某种意义上说，你知道。他也是个冷酷无情的人、花花公子以及其他许多事情。哦，对了，我忘了提那一部分。但他在这种英雄式且同时也是惨剧连连的方式中很有吸引力。而且有一些信件显示，当他输光了一大笔钱时，他独自一人身处新墨西哥州的沙漠里。
Coop invested what remained of his inheritance in silver prospects in the West, but those investments failed. His largest remaining asset was his personal fossil collection. Broke and without prospects, cope dropped out of the bone wars. Cope was a very sympathetic guy.
他就像那样独自一人走到那里，对吧，老兄？这里是蛮荒西部。他在写信，就像是，当时是深夜，他正在写信给他的女儿。你知道，他说，我希望我能看到你的脸，我孤零零地在这里。天气很冷。我今天找到了一些骨头。我担心财务问题。所有这些事情。
I mean, in a way, you know. He was also ruthless and a womanizer and many other things. Oh, yeah, I forgot to mention that part. But he's compelling in this sort of heroic and also train wreck way. And there are these letters where he's kind of when he lost a bunch of money, he's off in the desert in New Mexico.
这种对家人的哀怨之情。你可以想象他独自一人在星空下，思考着自己的人生。你知道，这很有趣。他的事业毁了，金钱没了，他的妻子也因为他是个花花公子而离开了他。科普正处于他人生的最低谷。
And he like just went out there by himself, like by himself, right, man? This is the Wild West. And he's writing, like, he's, it's nighttime and he's writing to his daughter. You know, and he's going, I wish I could see your face and I'm out here alone. It's cold. I found some bones today. I'm worried about finances. All of this stuff.
骨头大战本可以在这里结束，以马什的胜利告终，而科普的职业和个人生活则陷入了一片混乱。但这还远远不够。马什想把科普最珍贵的财产从他手中夺走。他想拿走那个人的骨头。而正是在这个时候，马什终于做得过火了。1889年12月16日，科普收到了一封来自内政部长的信，要求他将自己的个人化石收藏交出来给史密森尼学会。马什指控科普的化石是使用联邦资金收集的，因此必须被没收。
this sort of plaintive thing to his family. You can imagine his just being there under the stars alone, thinking about his life. And that's, you know, it's interesting. His career was ruined, his money was gone, and his wife had left him, you know, on account of him being a womanizer. Cope was at his lowest point.
并移交给政府。科普能够提供细致入微的财务记录，证明他个人资助了绝大部分的探险活动。他得以保留他的化石收藏，但现在他被彻底激怒了。科普准备给马什最后一击。多年来，科普收集了任何关于马什的投诉
The Bone Wars could have ended there, with Marsh on top, and Cope's professional and personal life in shambles. But that wasn't enough. Marsh wanted to pry Cope's most prized possession out of his hands. He wanted to take the man's bones. And this is when Marsh finally went too far. On December 16, 1889, Cope was sent a letter from the Secretary of the Interior demanding that he turned over his personal fossil collection to the Smithsonian Institution. Marsh had alleged that Cope's fossils had been collected using federal money and thus needed to be seized.
或可能的不端行为。再次请出马克·杰夫。他采访了许多心怀不满的助手，从他们那里收集故事，他把所有这些东西收集起来，称之为他的“马什iana”。他把它放在一个抽屉里。科普一直保留着一份基本上是绝密的档案，里面充满了针对马什的严重指控。其中包抄袭和滥用联邦资金的指控，特别是针对那些国家调查项目。他把这一切都交给了《纽约先驱报》的一位记者。
and turned over to the government. Cope was able to provide meticulous financial records proving that he personally funded the majority of his expeditions. He was allowed to keep his fossil collection, but now he was pissed. And Cope was ready to finally take Marsh down for good. For years in years, Cope had collected any complaint
后者最终兜售了一系列三部分的连载报道，揭露了马什。这篇报道发表于1890年1月。这场卑劣的科学争端从布满灰尘的学术论文直接跳到了各大报纸的头版。头条新闻写道：“科学家展开激烈交战。”同样，科学界的所有人都感到震惊。这就像是他们多年来一直在忍受的两人之间的战斗。在6点钟的新闻里，每个人都只希望这一切能消失。尽管对这个领域来说，目睹这一切是如此尴尬，
or possible near-do, well-doing by Marsh. Mark Jaffe again. He interviewed a lot of the disgruntled assistants, got stories from them, and he gathered all this stuff, and he called it his Marchiana. He kept it in a drawer. Cope had been keeping what was essentially a secret dossier full of terrible accusations against Marsh. It included allegations of plagiarism and abusing federal funds, specifically with those national surveys. And he handed all of it over to a journalist for the New York Herald. who ended up shopping around a series, three-part series, exposing marsh.
但骨头大战即将产生的后果将从学术政治波及到现实政治。他们设法做出的最具破坏性的事情，大概就是他们的恩怨如此臭名昭著，以至于国会议员们也注意到了这一点。当时的国会有一个保守派派系，急不可耐地想要削减科学经费。
And this landed in January of 1890. This petty scientific feud had jumped from dusty academic papers to the front page of major newspapers. The headline read, scientists wage bitter warfare. And again, everybody in the scientific community was just horrified. It was like this battle that they'd suffered for years and years between the two of them. On the 6 o'clock news, it was everyone just wanted it to go away. As embarrassing to the field as it was to witness,
就在那年早些时候，马什发表了一篇专著，描述了嘴里长满牙齿的史前鸟类化石。这其实是一项支持查尔斯·达尔文自然选择进化论的重要研究。而这正是阿拉巴马州的一位原教旨主义国会议员所需要的所有弹药。希拉里·赫伯特，我想，带着一本马什的《有牙齿的鸟》走进了国会，把这本书往桌上一摔，说道：“带牙齿的鸟！带牙齿的鸟！这就是你们纳税人的钱花的地方！带牙齿的鸟！”通过这些努力，美国地质调查局的资金被严重削减。当他的拨款在1892年被切断时，马什收到了来自美国地质调查局局长的
the bone wars were about to have consequences that would reverberate out of academic politics and into politics politics. Probably the most destructive thing they managed to do was to become so notorious for their feud that members of Congress managed to pick up on it. Congress at this time, had a conservative faction that was absolutely itching to slash its funding for the sciences.
一封严厉的电报，要求他辞职。但对马什来说，这还不是最糟的。因此，马什通过调查项目失去了资金。更糟糕的是，他被命令将调查项目收集的所有化石送到史密森尼学会。那可是大约80吨的化石。我想那是五六卡车的量。马什最终被撤职了。骨头大战似乎没有明显的赢家，就这样结束了。在这个过程中，两人把科学研究的联邦资金也一起搭了进去。
And earlier that year, Marsh published a monograph that described fossils of prehistoric birds with beaks full of teeth. It was actually important research that supported Charles Darwin's theory of evolution by natural selection. And it was all the ammunition one fundamentalist congressman from Alabama needed. Hillary Herbert, I believe, walked into Congress with a copy of Marsh's Birds with Teethys and slammed this book down and said, Birds with teeth. Birds with teeth. This is where your taxpayer dollars are going. Birds with teeth. And through those efforts, the USGS was severely defunded. When his appropriation was cut off in 1892, Marsh received a terse telegram from the director
科普可能赢得了媒体大战，但他依然一贫如洗。他在一生中积累了大量的化石收藏，多到他有两栋房子，一栋给自己住，一栋用来放他所有的骨头。他最终卖掉了他整个收藏来偿还累累债务。是的，今天的博物馆人挺多的，我猜是因为假期的原因，但这个大厅总是很挤。科普庞大的藏品被美国自然历史博物馆买下，迈克尔·诺维切克博士在那里得以指出他的一些最伟大的发现。这是异特龙。哦，是的。
of the USGS demanding his resignation. But that wasn't even the worst of it for Marsh. So Marsh lost his funding through the survey. And more than that was ordered to send all the fossils collected by the survey down to the Smithsonian. That was like 80 tons of fossils. I think it was five or six carloads. Marsh was ultimately removed from his position. And the Bone Wars ended, seemingly with no obvious winner. And in the process, the two had taken down federal funding for scientific research with them.
它是一种比侏罗纪时期的霸王龙更古老的掠食者。而且它，你知道，体型稍小一点，但看起来依然很凶猛。科普于1897年去世，享年56岁。即使在生命的尽头，他仍然无法抗拒来自墓穴的最后一击。科普实际上向马什发起了挑战。这是耶鲁皮博迪博物馆的博物馆助理丹·布林克曼。所以科普把他的遗体捐给了科学。他希望把自己的大脑和马什的大脑进行比较，
Cope may have won the press war, but he was still broke. He had amassed an enormous collection of fossils over his lifetime, so many that he had two houses, one for himself and one for all of his bones. He eventually sold his entire collection to cover his many debts. Yeah, the museum's pretty crowded today, I guess, because of the holidays, but this hall is always crowded. Cope's massive collection was purchased by the American Museum of Natural History, where Dr. Michael Novichek was able to, to point out some of his greatest discoveries. This is Allosaurus. Oh, yeah.
以证明谁的头脑更聪明。马什最终没有上钩，仅仅两年后他也去世了，大脑没有被取出，身边也没有家人或朋友陪伴。这让我想起了《公民凯恩》的开场白，你知道。查尔斯·福斯特·凯恩躺在床上，是的，除了他说的可能是“雷龙”。但讽刺的是，人们总是把他们联系在一起，你知道，科普和马什，就像阿博特和科斯特洛。你知道，你几乎不能只说一个人的名字而不提另一个。
It's an older predator than Tyrannosaurus from the Jurassic. And it, you know, a little smaller, but still ferocious looking. Cope died in 1897 at the age of 56. And even at the end of his life, couldn't resist taking one more swipe from beyond the grave. Cope actually challenged Marsh. This is Dan Brinkman, museum assistant at the Yale Peabody Museum. So Cope gave his body to science. He wanted his brain compared with Marsh's brain
我想他们是不会喜欢这样的。两人加起来一共发现了超过25,000个新化石。他们还共同收集并描述了136种恐龙。这两人发现了当今世人所熟知的许多最具代表性的恐龙物种，包括三角龙、剑龙、异特龙和梁龙。如果你想看最终的比分，马什因发现80种新恐龙而受到赞誉，而科普则发现了56种。气死你了吧，科普。然而，在这两者之间，如今被认为有效的物种仅有32种。
to show who was the brainier of the two. Mars did not end up taking the bait, and he died just two years later, brain unremoveed, but with no family or friends by his side. It sort of reminds me of like the opening scene of Citizen Kane, you know. Charles Schwarzen-Cain is there in bed, yeah, except he says like, Prontosaurus. But the irony is they're known together, you know, Copen Marsh, Abbott and Costello. You know, it's just can't hardly say one name without the other.
为了证明两人究竟谁更聪明。马什最终没有上钩，仅仅两年后他就去世了，大脑并没有被切除，但身旁没有家人或朋友陪伴。这有点让我想起《公民凯恩》的开场白，你知道的。查尔斯·施瓦辛格-凯恩躺在床上，是的，除了他说了句类似“雷龙”的话。但讽刺的是，他们现在总是被一起提及，你知道的，科普与马什，就像阿博特和科斯特洛。你知道，你几乎不能只说其中一个名字而不带上另一个。
I don't think they would have liked that. Combined, the two of them discovered over 25,000 new fossils. Together, they also collected and described 136 dinosaurs. The two discovered many of the most recognizable species of dinosaurs known today, including Triceratops, Stegosaurus, Allosaurus, and Diplodocus. And if you want the final score, Marsh is credited with 80 new dinosaurs to Cope's 56. In your face, Cope. However, between the two of them, only 32 of those species are considered valid today.
我想他们不会喜欢这样。两人加起来一共发现了超过25,000个新化石。他们还共同收集并描述了136种恐龙。两人发现了当今许多最具辨识度的恐龙物种，包括三角龙、剑龙、异特龙和梁龙。如果要算最终比分，马什发现了80种新恐龙，而科普发现了56种。气死你了吧，科普。然而，在他们两人发现的所有物种中，如今被认为依然有效的只有32种。
That means roughly 76% of everything they named was either a duplicate, a misidentification, or based on such fragmentary bones that it couldn't be properly classified. It was a product of their mad rush to be on top. In the end, both men were left battered and bruised reputationalally. They were considered an embarrassment by the scientific community. But ultimately, both men's work accelerated the field of paleontology from a fledgling science to something worthy of the public's attention. They also furthered the reputations of two of the most renowned natural history museums in the world. And isn't it ironic that out of this horrible kind of competition, it's more in competition, it was a fight, a feud, came this brilliant result.
这意味着他们命名的所有东西中，大约有 76% 要么是重复命名，要么是错误鉴定，要么是基于极其残缺的骨骼，根本无法正确分类。这是他们急于拔头筹的狂热产物。最终，两个人的声誉都受到了打击。他们被科学界视为一种尴尬。但归根结底，这两个人的工作将古生物学这门羽翼未丰的科学推进到了值得公众关注的领域。他们还提升了世界上两个最著名的自然历史博物馆的声誉。讽刺的是，在经历了这种可怕的竞争之后，更准确地说，是一场争斗、一场宿怨，竟然诞生了如此辉煌的成果。
Dr. Michael Novichick again. It was really the big spark for the growth of those museums and the establishment of the museums. I mean, dinosaurs are popular. Giant mammal fossils are popular, and people flock to them. And so the Carnegie, the Peabody, the American Museum in Natural History, the Smithsonian, the Philadelphia Academy, and more. We're all, all, you know, catalyzed by,
迈克尔·诺维奇克（Dr. Michael Novichick）再次说道。这确实是推动这些博物馆发展和建立的巨大火花。我的意思是，恐龙很受欢迎。巨型哺乳动物化石也很受欢迎，人们蜂拥而至。因此，卡耐基博物馆、皮博迪博物馆、美国自然历史博物馆、史密森尼学会、费城科学院等等，全都被……你知道的，催化了这一切。
all this collection in the west of these fossils. But personally, I think the most important impact of this silly rivalry was creating generations of dinosaur kids, like me. Wow, can I ask if these kids like dinosaurs? While I was wandering around the Yale P. Body Museum, the place that owes its existence to this feud, I came across a couple of kids visiting with their family, and I knew exactly how they felt.
所有这些在西部收集的化石。但就我个人而言，我认为这场无聊的竞争最重要的影响是培养了一代又一代的恐龙迷，就像我一样。哇，我可以问问这些孩子们喜欢恐龙吗？当我漫步在耶鲁皮博迪博物馆时——这个地方的存在要归功于这场宿怨——我遇到了几个随家人来参观的孩子，我完全理解他们的感受。
How can I describe how it felt to stare up at a T-Rex skeleton when I was five years old? To feel like there's finally something in real life that matches up to your wild imagination. Their presence made the museum a magical place that I couldn't get enough of, and I wanted to know more, more, more about dinosaurs. I wanted to memorize their names and wear dinosaur pajamas and drink out of a dinosaur cup. They told me the world was full of wonder and things to be discovered. I'm reporting a podcast about dinosaurs. I wanted to ask, do you like dinosaurs?
我该如何形容五岁时抬头凝视霸王龙骨架时的感觉呢？那种感觉就好像现实生活中终于有一样东西能够与你疯狂的想象力相契合。他们的存在让博物馆变成了一个充满魔力的地方，让我流连忘返，我还想了解更多、更多、更多的恐龙。我想背住它们的名字，穿恐龙睡衣，用恐龙杯子喝水。他们告诉我，这个世界充满了奇迹和等待被发现的事物。我正在做一个关于恐龙的播客。我想问一下，你们喜欢恐龙吗？
Yeah, and want me to tell you something. I really like saber-tooth tigers because antidectors because saber-toothed and thunderdog power and power angels. Uh-huh. I'm the yellow angel. You are? And what do you like about dinosaurs? Some of them eat plants and some of them.
是的，想听我说点什么吗。我真的很喜欢剑齿虎，因为防腐剂……因为剑齿虎和雷狗的力量和力量天使。嗯哼。我是黄色天使。你是吗？你喜欢恐龙的什么？它们有的吃植物，有的吃……
I'm all super cool because they can run fast, blend in, and also they can run fast like saber to the tiger. Did you know? And also fly. Yeah. Well, what's that dinosaur? I don't know, but these people would know. Professor Marge named Bron tops. Brontops.
我觉得它们超级酷，因为它们能跑得很快、能伪装，而且它们还能像剑齿虎一样跑得很快。你知道吗？而且还会飞。是的。嗯，那是什么恐龙？我不知道，但这些人会知道。马奇教授把它命名为雷龙（Bron tops）。雷龙（Brontops）。
Is that your new favorite dinosaur? No. No. Thank you so much for taking the time to talk to me. I hope you have the best time at the museum today. Okay. Say bye. Bye.
那是你最喜欢的新恐龙吗？不是。不是。非常感谢你抽出时间和我聊天。我希望你今天在博物馆玩得最开心。好。说拜拜。拜拜。
Bye. Thank you. A few corrections with Gileon Jacobs. After this, we are back with a reporter and dinosaur enthusiast Gillian Jacobs. Hey, Gileon. Hi, Roman. Am I now the official dinosaur correspondent for 99PI? You are the official correspondent of many things.
再见。谢谢。与吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）一起进行的一些纠错。接下来，我们将与记者兼恐龙爱好者吉莉安·雅各布斯一起回归。嘿，吉莉安。嗨，罗曼。我现在是 99PI 的官方恐龙记者了吗？你是许多事物的官方记者。
Pittsburgh, Los Angeles, waterways, and dinosaurs. I'm so glad it's now clear to you how much I love dinosaurs, and I'm glad the world knows. In fact, I dressed as a dinosaur on an episode of community, as a, homage to my childhood love for dinosaurs. Really? You might not have noticed or remembered because everybody said I looked like Yoshi, but I was supposed to be a T-Rex. That's awesome.
匹兹堡、洛杉矶、水道和恐龙。我很高兴你现在清楚我有多么热爱恐龙，我也很高兴全世界都知道这一点。事实上，我在一集《废柴联盟》（Community）中打扮成了一只恐龙，以此向我童年对恐龙的热爱致敬。真的吗？你可能没有注意到或不记得了，因为每个人都说我看起来像耀西（Yoshi），但我本意是要扮成一只霸王龙。那太棒了。
So as we covered in the main episode, Cope and Marsh, they advanced the field of paleontology a lot in their work, but they also made a ton of mistakes along the way. And we're here to talk about those mistakes. Yes, and I want to preface this with the fact that paleontology is a field where it is very easy to make very big errors. Paleontologists are constantly trying to correct the scientific record because constructing entire extinct ecosystems based on very, very old and broken bones is very difficult, even today. So no judgments for me.
正如我们在正片中提到的那样，科普（Cope）和马什（Marsh）在他们的工作中极大地推动了古生物学领域的发展，但他们在过程中也犯了大量的错误。我们今天就是来聊聊这些错误的。是的，我想在前面加一句：古生物学是一个很容易犯巨大错误的领域。古生物学家们一直在努力修正科学记录，因为根据非常非常古老且破碎的骨骼来构建整个灭绝的生态系统是非常困难的，即使在今天也是如此。所以我不会做任何评判。
Got it. That being said, the mistakes that Cope and Marsh made definitely weren't helped by the speed in which they were working just so they could outdo each other. That's right. Some of this was self-inflicted harm. So what are some examples of the things they got wrong? Okay, so we know that the whole bone wars were actually kicked off by a really big slip-up. Here's Mark Jaffe, author of The Gilded Dinosaur again.
明白了话虽如此，科普和马什犯下的错误，绝对与他们为了压倒对方而盲目追求工作速度脱不了干系。没错。其中一些可以说是他们自找的麻烦。那么，他们搞砸的事情都有哪些例子呢？好吧，我们知道，整个“化石战争”其实是由一个非常大的失误引发的。这里再次请出《镀金恐龙》（The Gilded Dinosaur）的作者马克·贾菲（Mark Jaffe）。
The single biggest mistake in paleontology was Marsh's. He made a mistake that stood for decades. So in the thick of the bone wars, Marsh described to name the species of sauropod, which is a type of dinosaur with a very long neck and a very long tail. And he named this a patosaurus. Well, a couple of years later, his team found the remains of another sauropod, this one much bigger, which Marsh believed belonged to an entirely new species. He had this nearly complete skeleton, again, very rare. All it lacked was a head. And they couldn't find it in the quarry that they were working in. But they found a nice, complete scope at another quarry, four miles away. So he said, all right, we're going to put that head on this one.
古生物学中最大的错误是马什犯下的。他犯了一个持续了几十年的错误。在“化石战争”最激烈的时候，马什描述并命名了一个蜥脚类恐龙物种，这是一种脖子很长、尾巴也很长的恐龙。他将其命名为迷惑龙（Apatosaurus）。然而几年后，他的团队发现了另一只蜥脚类恐龙的遗骸，这只体型大得多，马什认为它属于一个全新的物种。他拥有这具几乎完整的骨架，这再次证明它非常罕见。它唯一缺的就是一个头部。而且他们在工作的采石场里没有找到它。但他们在四英里外的另一个采石场发现了一个非常完整的大圆顶（头骨）。于是他说：“好吧，我们要把那个头安到这个身体上。”
And he called it the brontosaurus. Well, there's no such thing as a brontosaurus. What the brontosaurus was, was an apatosaurus body with a chemosaurus head. And sort of the irony was that for years, many paleontologists sort of, that's not right. That's not right. But because it was Marsh, it's all right, I'm not going to take that on. It took almost 60 years before everybody owned up. Yeah, yeah, there's no such thing as a rhinosaurus.
他把它叫做雷龙（Brontosaurus）。嗯，根本没有什么雷龙。所谓的雷龙，其实是一个迷惑龙的身体安上了一个长颈龙（Camarasaurus）的头。具有讽刺意味的是，多年来许多古生物学家觉得“这不对，这不对”。但因为那是马什，大家觉得“好吧，我可不去触这个霉头”。差不多过了 60 年，大家才承认错误。对，对，根本没有雷龙这种东西。
I've heard this before, but I think there's probably a bunch of people who don't know that bronosaurus never actually existed. Like, it's still kind of in the top five of dinosaurs that people know. But actually, it was an apatosaurus the whole time, which is the wrong skull. Yeah, so the actual name Brontosaurus went unused by paleontologists for around 100 years. And it actually wasn't even until 1979 that the Carnegie Museum corrected the head on its own skeleton. But I am sure that there are some listeners out there who are dinosaur enthusiasts. And when Bronosaurus came up in the main story, thought, that's not even a real dinosaur. Right.
我以前听说过这个，但我认为可能还有很多人不知道雷龙其实根本不存在。就像，它在人们所知的恐龙中仍然排在前五位。但实际上，它从头到尾都是迷惑龙，只是顶着个错误的头骨。是的，所以“雷龙”这个真正的名字被古生物学家闲置了大约 100 年。直到 1979 年，卡耐基博物馆才纠正了其自家骨架上的头骨。但我确信，听众中一定有一些恐龙爱好者，当正片中提到雷龙时，会想：“那根本不是真正的恐龙。”没错。
And there's probably a few who are like, what are you talking about? Bronosaurus is like one of the big five. Yeah, that was my favorite dinosaur. Yeah, I love that one. You're rewriting my childhood. Exactly. And I'm about to make it even more complicated because in 2015, there was a study that concluded that there were enough differences between apatosaurus and bronosaurus to distinguish it as a separate genus. and that the name Bronosaurus should be revived.
可能还有少数人会想：“你在说什么？雷龙可是五大恐龙之一。”是的，那是我最喜欢的恐龙。是的，我超喜欢那个。你简直是在重塑我的童年。没错。而且我接下来要让事情变得更复杂，因为在 2015 年，有一项研究得出结论：迷惑龙和雷龙之间存在足够多的差异，足以将其区分为一个独立的属，并且“雷龙”这个名字应该被重新启用。
Oh, my God. It's still being debated within paleontology. Emily Grassley described it as the Pluto of the dinosaur world. That sounds like a very apt metaphor where people are fighting over something with great fervor that probably doesn't matter all that much. Watch yourself. The comment section's about to light up. Okay. So what else do these two guys get wrong?
天哪。古生物学界目前还在争论不休。埃米莉·格拉斯利（Emily Grassley）将其描述为“恐龙世界的冥王星”。这听起来像是一个非常贴切的比喻，人们为了一件可能无关紧要的事情争得面红耳赤、充满热情。小心点。评论区马上就要炸了。好吧。这两个家伙还搞错了什么？
So the next one came from Cope. So Cope was known for being an incredibly fast writer, and he would just fire off paper after paper after paper. And Dan Brinkman at the Peabody Museum told me about a mistake he made that was more of a clerical error than a taxonomic error as he was rushing to beat Marsh to publication. Cope had kind of poor handwriting that alone when he's writing by a lamplight at Cam. But a poor telegrapher in Blackbeaut, Wyoming got this such line description that he was to telegraph back to Philadelphia. Cope had intended to name one of these animals, Loxalafidon, which means beast with crested tooth. But the poor telegrapher, trying to make it out, bastardized it into Leffalafidon, which is pure gibberish. Well, that's happened to all of us, I think.
接下来的一个错误来自科普。科普以写作速度极快而闻名，他会接连不断地发表论文。皮博迪博物馆的丹·布林克曼（Dan Brinkman）告诉我，他犯了一个错误，与其说是一个分类学错误，不如说是一个文书错误，因为他当时正赶着抢在马什之前发表。科普的字迹本来就有点糟糕，当他在凌晨的煤油灯下写作时更是如此。但在怀俄明州布莱克福特（Black Butte）的一个糟糕的电报员收到了这样一行描述，他需要把这行描述电报回费城。科普原本打算给其中一种动物命名为 Loxalafidon，意思是“长着冠状牙齿的野兽”。但那个倒霉的电报员为了辨认清楚，把它曲解成了 Leffalafidon，这纯粹是胡言乱语。好吧，我想我们所有人都遇到过这种情况。
Absolutely. I'm glad I can spell my own name some days. The next one is actually a double oopsie from Marsh. So Marsh first describes Stegosaurus in 1877. Pop Quiz Roman, what does a stegosaurus look like? Yeah, I know exactly what Stegosaurus looks like. You cannot stump me here. It is the four-footed dinosaur. It's one of the big sort of like one of the big humpback and it has the bony sails. like a mohawk on its spine and has a spiky tail that it uses to like fight other dinosaurs with. Ding, ding, ding. Exactly correct.
确实如此。有几天我能拼对自己的名字就很高兴了。下一个其实是马什的“双重乌龙”。马什在 1877 年首次描述了剑龙。随堂小考，罗曼，剑龙长什么样？是的，我非常清楚剑龙长什么样。你绝对难不倒我。它是一种四足行走的恐龙。它是那种体型巨大、有点驼背的动物，背上有骨质的帆，就像脊椎上的莫霍克发型一样，还有带刺的尾巴，用来和其他恐龙打架。叮叮叮。完全正确。
So it's got those plates that stick up all the way down its back and down the tail, like you said, kind of like a mohawk. But Marsh pictured the bony plates lying flat across the animal's back like roof shingles or like a suit of armor, which is actually where the name Stegosaurus comes from because it means roofed lizard. And it took years of later analysis and better fossil evidence for paleontologists to work out that the plates almost certainly stood upright in two staggered rows down the spine, not flat, not armor, more likely for display or temperature regulation. I'm glad they corrected it to be upright because that looks way cooler. Yeah, you're right. It is so much cooler. But my favorite mistake that Marsh theorized about the stegosaurus was that it possibly had two brains.
所以它背上和尾巴上长满了直立的骨板，就像你说的，有点像莫霍克发型。但马什想象那些骨质骨板平铺在动物的背上，就像屋顶的瓦片或一套盔甲，这也是“剑龙”这个名字的由来，因为它意思是“有屋顶的蜥蜴”。后来经过多年的分析和更好的化石证据，古生物学家才弄清楚，这些骨板几乎可以肯定是沿着脊椎错落有致地排成两行竖直站立的，而不是平铺的，也不是盔甲，更有可能是为了展示或调节体温。我很高兴他们把它修正为竖直的，因为那样看起来酷多了。是的，你说得对。确实酷多了。但我最喜欢的关于剑龙的错误是，马什推测它可能有两颗大脑。
and one of those brains was in its butt. I do remember this now that you mention it, like a walnut-sized brain in his butt. But why did he think this? So he noticed that the neural canal running through the sacrum, which is the fused vertebra at the hip, widened into a large empty cavity in its bottom half that no one could explain.
其中一颗大脑在它的屁股里。经你这么一说，我确实想起来了，就像屁股里有一个核桃大小的大脑。但为什么他会这么想呢？他注意到，穿过荐骨（也就是臀部融合的椎骨）的神经管在其下半部分扩大成了一个巨大的空腔，谁也无法解释这是为什么。
And he also noted that the Stegosaurus had an unusually tiny brain for its body, so it was possible that the second cavity could be some kind of secondary nerve center that could help coordinate the mass of hind legs and the spiked tail. Like kind of how those big fire trucks have like two drivers, like one at the front and one at the back just to make sure that you can make a tight corner. Yes, exactly that. That's awesome. Okay, I have to be serious.
他还注意到，与它的体型相比，剑龙的大脑异常微小，因此第二个空腔有可能是某种次级神经中枢，可以帮助协调笨重的后腿和带刺的尾巴。就像那些大型消防车有两个驾驶员一样，前面一个，后面一个，只是为了确保你能通过急弯。是的，完全是这样。这太棒了。好吧，我得严肃一点。
Like I said, paleontology is hard and none of this is meant to dunk on Copenhagen Marsh specifically. And paleontology corrects itself constantly. That's the whole point of science. But the way these two guys acted, that could probably use a little humbling. That's right. That's right. A lot of this is they're being sort of hoisted on their own pittard. We're not making fun of general science, which involves a lot of, you know, discussion and conflict and people fighting over ideas and revision. And it's good when people revise things. That's the whole story of science. Exactly.
就像我说的，古生物学很难，这些都不是为了专门贬低科普和马什。而且古生物学一直在自我修正。这正是科学的意义所在。但这两个家伙当年的行事风格，确实有点需要受点挫折。没错。没错。很大程度上，他们这是搬起石头砸了自己的脚。我们不是在取笑一般性的科学，科学本身包含大量的讨论、冲突、人们为观点而争论以及修正。人们能修正错误是一件好事。这就是科学的全部历史。确实。
So thank you so much for bringing us the amazing story of the Bone Wars. It's fun to geek out about dinosaurs with you. I don't think I could enjoy anything more. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Gillian Jacobs and edited by Vivian Lay with additional production by Jacob Medina Gleason. Mixed by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Special thanks this week to Leslie M.M. Bloom.
非常感谢你给我们带来关于“化石战争”的精彩故事。和你一起狂热地聊恐龙太有趣了。我想我找不到比这更享受的事了。本周的《99%无形》（99% Invisible）由吉莉安·雅各布斯（Gillian Jacobs）报道，维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）剪辑，雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）参与制作。混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）完成，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）制作。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Hesha）完成。本周特别鸣谢莱斯利·M·M·布鲁姆（Leslie M.M. Bloom）。
Kathy 2 is our executive producer, Kurt Colstead, is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashemaddon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Tallinn and Rain Stradley, and Me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible Logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server.
凯茜·2（Kathy 2）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、拉舍马·多恩（Lashemaddon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利（Tallin and Rain Stradley），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一员，现在总部设在北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼（Pandora building）。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。
There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99P. p.i.org There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里有指向 99P.i.org 的链接以及 99PI 以往每一集的链接。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。